you hurt both quads making this film by
cordial and Julie yeah Wow
yeah it was a we did this whole scene
and rocks falling on her hands I thought
it'd be super awesome if I smash down to
my knees it was brilliant the director
chef did cut it is perfect do it again
and unfortunately and we did it like 29
times and I pulled my cords and got
tendinitis in my knee and I watched the
movie I watched the trailer and he was
like it's gonna look great in the movie
it's going to look good in the movie I
watched the trailer and it's like blink
and you miss it and I swear to god it
could have been my wonderful stuntman
yes you don't know it's me
yeah so I'm really glad I did it so wait
so these are serious injuries I don't
have quads so I don't know what you're
talking about babe no musculature at all
but but we're right to have it what this
is serious like this must have really
hurt a great deal did it take you a long
time to recover I had six months of
tendinitis in my knee right it's really
hard for me I know yeah it's a hard life
as an actor who else now bill did you do
your own stunts here we're doing their
stunts were you encouraged to do your
own stunts oh yeah no like James was
jumping off of things
isaiah pj j everybody was doing all
these crazy stunts and then i was asked
to run and I ran like ten feet and
pulled my groin I literally ran there
like all right action I ran and just
went Hospital no I didn't have the cool
like James action no no no I'm a I'm
yeah I'm like you I don't have quad
well let's no okay but I hung out at a
groin yeah you do have a grass yeah well
you're ahead of me there
Isiah your strong feeling is that these
injuries could have been avoided
yeah you've need a warm-up and stretch
it's not that I've run away from clowns
all the time but I knew better I knew to
warm up and stretch because because we
would be running away from a clown they
say it's okay warm up so yeah I mean and
also yeah you're a real athlete I mean
yeah well I was yeah but you know so so
you were stretching beforehand yeah it
was a little like I did like like you
know I was that's what I do on a hot
beat ia ia ia so a little stretching and
this all could have been avoided is what
you say man the other actors the other
actors they were sitting in the room
good did the character get to warm up
fuzzy oh yeah yeah the caryharri Ricky
you would know what he warmed up for 27
years
yeah years since they're a KU burn on
Yale Denver